[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et le début d'une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv 78 bienvenue dans cette édition
tout de suite les titres de ce lundi 4
juin
un parcours à vélo à travers la france
pour sensibiliser aux changements
climatiques le tour alternative à des
buts en ce mois de juin
hier à cette occasion une étape du tour
se tenait à vélizy un village des
alternatives étaient notamment installés
pour l'événement
reportage à suivre depuis 1968 à led et
accueille les personnes en situation de
handicap de tout âge ainsi que leurs
familles
l'association pour l'insertion
l'éducation et les soins fête ses 50 ans
cette année
un anniversaire célébré ce week-end par
la structure basée à trappes nous en
parlons avec son président josé lucas
enfin du football du en cours a remporté
hier à la finale de la coupe des
yvelines à maisons-laffitte succès dans
un match 100% saint quentinois face à
maurepas
le résumé de la rencontre enfin
d'édition et puis nous recevrons
également sur ce plateau aline grillon
du secours populaire des yvelines la
fédération organise cet été son deuxième
village copains du monde mais d'abord
160 migrants accueilli ce lundi dans les
yvelines ils font partie des personnes
évacuées ce matin des campements eaux du
canal saint-martin et de la porte des
poissonniers à paris 65 migrants ont été
mises à l'abri à louveciennes 55 abonnés
les 40 à saint germain en laye une
solution d'hébergement temporaire en
attente d'un examen complet de leur
situation administrative par les
services de l'état
hier dimanche à vélizy donc a été lancée
le tour alternatiba d'ile-de-france au
coeur des festivités un village des
alternatives qui regroupait différentes
associations locales engagées pour
l'environnement l'alimentation ou encore
la solidarité
reportage de camille lambert et nicolas
landry
des légumes des fruits des plantes
aromatiques et des conseils pour
cultiver ces types de produits
l'objectif de cette graine au tec une
vingtaine d'associations participer au
village éphémère alternatiba de vélizy
avec comme thème l'autonomie partage
d'expériences et activités ludiques
notamment pour apprendre à construire un
nichoir pour les oiseaux du bois
bien coupé enfin comme il faut les
mesures et des clous pour que ça
s'accroche c'est bien c'est surtout pour
les enfants et puis même noens et c'est
très intéressant
je pense que c'est important d'être
sensibilisés à la planète et à ce qu'on
laisse à nos enfants et de les
sensibiliser aussi parce que c'est
finalement qui vont faire l'avenir
le collectif alternatiba veut
sensibiliser de manière festive aux
enjeux climatiques et sociétaux avec
comme principe des solutions locales aux
dérèglements mondial dans chaque
alternatiba ont choisi ce qui nous
touche le plus alors ça peut être en
ville ça peut être la circulation douce
ça peut être les économies des ders
d'énergie ça peut être le
le solaire le trier ses déchets créer
des recycleries est donc en fait ce
qu'on fait actuellement on demande aux
associations et aux particuliers de nous
dire ce qui les touche le plus
ce qui touche énormément en région
parisienne en fait c'est les
déplacements donc plus de pistes
cyclables c'est aussi beaucoup ça je
pense de partout là les cantines bio
le collectif alternatiba de versailles
prévoit d'organiser un défi zéro déchet
famille sur l'agglomération de
versailles grand parc à partir du mois
de septembre
on accueille sur ce plateau josé lucas
bonsoir bonsoir mieux ça vous vous êtes
le président de l'ess et l'association
pour l'insertion l'éducation et les sons
alors cette structure est basée à
attraper elle fêtait ce week-end ses 50
ans était sur le site du mais rente ai à
magny les hameaux 50 ans pour une
association première question ça si ça
signifie quoi est ce que c'est la preuve
du travail bien fait sur sur 50 ans
justement on a eu la preuve hier avec le
monde avec canal on s'est vraiment très
très important 50 ans na demi siècle ce
qui a été fait à l'époque en 68 parle
monsieur bernard hugo ce qu'est ce que
l'association maintenant je crois qui a
vraiment lancé un réel succès garner
hugo qu'on entendra leurs matin vers 9
heures et qui a été avec nous hier donc
non non c'est un réel réel succès alors
la us se fixe pour but de mieux répondre
à l'accompagnement des personnes en
situation de handicap et ceux de tout
âge comment ça se traduit concrètement
dans vogue dans vos actions comment se
met en place justement cet
accompagnement
cet accord bénéficie les 5000 et il est
basé en fait sur des établissements
aujourd'hui la lyonnaise se gère neuf
établissements l'on pourra rappeler
l'historique un petit peu aujourd'hui
ces neuf établissements tous les âges
l'agrément surtout petits seins les tout
petits avec qui ont les plus petits
bords entre quatre et cinq ans pour
aller jusqu'aux adultes vieillissants
donc qui sont situés qu'on a qui sont
aujourd'hui en service d'accueil de jour
où mes rentes elle vient le site sur
lequel on l'était hier
et c'est vrai qu'on suit absolument tous
les âges le but pour les yeux ce temps
de récupérer pour les petits les
récupérer le plus vite possible pour
pouvoir leur apporter un accompagnement
le plus rapidement possible et les
remettre un petit peu dans un chemin qui
leur permet d'avoir une vie sociale et
d'entrée complètement dans la dans la
société
ces structures d'accueil elles sont de
deux types
différents elles sont de type différent
bien évidemment puisque ce ne sont pas
les mêmes il n'y a pas là on n'est pas
sur les mêmes âges donc et on a
aujourd'hui des structures qui sont
adaptés on en a deux grands pôles et on
a un pôle enfance adolescence et un pôle
adulte bien évidemment les structures ne
sont pas les mêmes les pôles adultes par
exemple on fait travailler sont des
travailleurs des travail et handicapés
qui ont donc un emploi qui rentre dans
la société sur les pour la partie sur la
partie enfance on a deux types
d'établissements les ime où ils sont à
100% avec nous d'accord et les cézanne
ou là ils sont intégrés dans l'école
avec des passages permanent au niveau de
la structure qui les aide à
l'accompagnement aider à développer leur
potentiel
cinquante ans d'existence pour cette
association vous ça fait plus de vingt
ans que vous êtes en guerre nous
cessions dans l'association est ce que
vous de votre point de vue la perception
du handicap a évolué sur ces dernières
années ce que l'accompagnement va dans
le bon sens aujourd'hui l'évolution de
la vie danse ça va dans le bon sens le
problème c'est que de plus en plus on se
heurte à des problèmes de budget il faut
être très clair il ya pas que nous
associations ont honoré le vivant dans
les handicaps 1 c'est la même chose je
pense que tous les gens qui passent là
vous dit de neige aux problèmes de
budget donc ça s'est passé
ça nous pose des problèmes notamment
ceux au niveau des recrutements le
secteur du médico social n'est pas
quelque chose qui attire énormément on a
besoin de personnel y performer qui sont
capables de vraiment de d'accompagner
les enfants qui sont en difficulté c'est
pas toujours très simple voilà on a
emmené à ce problème
ensuite ces problèmes de projets qu'on
ne peut pas assister m en aurez plein
d'idées de projets mais on est obligé
d'attendre un appel à projets et donc
c'est vrai que c'est pas si simple que
ça mais globalement on peut dire que oui
en étant l'amélioration ou entre la
situation il ya cinquante ans est la
situation aujourd'hui comme une mesure
ont d'ailleurs l'une de vos missions
c'est aussi de sensibiliser le public
sur la question du handicap
alors c'est plus difficile c'est plus
difficile mais on le fait un dès qu'on
peut le faire on a c'est une
sensibilisation est très très importante
maintenant c'est pas si simple que ça
donc que ces séances en civil au maximum
de ce qu'on peut sensibiliser
on y arrive relativement bien alors la
us sont lady a fêté ses 50 ans ce week
end à magny les hameaux son fondateur
bernard hugo ancien maire de trappes
étaient présents écoutez le au micro de
michel et demi d'euros c'est
complètement différent de ce que nous
avons pu créé en 1968
et c'est devenu une association
extrêmement important que les ventes
nous avons mis sur pied pas mal d
équipement qui existent aujourd'hui mais
qui aujourd'hui se développe avec kéké
qui semble maintenant au niveau de saint
quentin en yvelines
alors qu'au départ c'est être ap ap ap
ap tout seul avec bernard hugo le dit
complètement différent de ce qu'il a
avait créé à l'époque à l'époque ça
s'appelait l'association municipale pour
la réinsertion sociale et
professionnelle de trappes donc ça
c'était lors sa création en 1968
aujourd'hui la structure liste élargie à
plusieurs que cette énergie
il n'empêche qu'au niveau de notre
conseil d'administration retrouve la
moitié des élus qui sont des élus
membres dont qui sont des demandes et
des gens qui figureront l'association
qui participe et la moitié sont des
représentants des communes d'accord là
par exemple trois représentants de ski
on a le conseil départemental
on a des représentants de trois communes
et tourne à tour de rôle on est on est
ils sont avec nous au ca ou penser
ministration donc ça reste quand même il
ya toujours une une connotation saint
quentin en yvelines qui est très
importante et l'essentiel de l'eau
centre s'ouvre sur saint quentin
par contre on a exactement on a repris
en 2017
on a fusionné avec une autre association
qui s'appelle appelé dicks qui était à
la celle saint cloud et qui avait
exactement la même structure que tu es
une structure municipale qui avait été
créée à peu près dans les mêmes mains
dans les mêmes dates en 72 et eux ont
intégré complètement la us qui nous
permet maintenant d'avoir une très
grosse structure avec neuf centres et
voilà on y retrouve eux sont aussi
sortis de ce contexte purement municipal
nation d'un point depuis 1968 quelles
ont été les grandes étapes d'évolution
les points clés de l'histoire de la us
dans les points clés c'est le
développement permanent c'est la
recherche de développement c'était
beaucoup plus facile dans le passé
puisqu'on pouvait aller les projets on
pouvait les initiés ce qu'a fait bernard
hugo en 68
aujourd'hui ce que possible de dire je
crée un établissement et je demande
d'agrément après aujourd'hui ça se passe
pas du tout changé de forme
donc ce qui a été fait dans les
premières années le développement ou pas
sont deux par tranche d'âge on s'était
lui c'était 7 c'était de 2 7 à 14 ans
ensuite il ya eu un centre pour 14 20
ans puis ensuite les adultes
puis ensuite plein plein de choses on a
fait la dernière les uns des grands
projets de laïos c'est la reprise donc
de la gestion du site numérotée un site
dédié à la gérontologie et donc ont géré
ça depuis maintenant depuis un peu plus
de six mois donc c'est ça se passe très
très bien aussi il fallait faire revivre
ce site alors le site vous l'avez pas vu
milly magnifique donc un héros tels le
domaine militaire amani leo manidem une
dernière réaction à vous faire écouter
une vision actuelle du maire de trappes
l'actuel maire de trappes dit malandain
qui est également présent samedi écouter
quel regard il porte sur l' us
d'abord c'est tu c'est une histoire
humaine d'engagement de deux personnes
dans des institutions qui se sont
spécialisés professionnaliser et et puis
le deuxième élément c'est que ce qui ce
qui se passe ici dans les différentes
instances j'allais dire les différents
lieux d'intervention de de la rs c'est
au service de personnes jeunes gens
jeunes filles hommes femmes qui ont
besoin d'une aide particulière d'un
humanisme particulier et tous ceux qui y
travaillent ah là là sont des gens
remarquables
aujourd'hui de quelle importance at-elle
cette association pour le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines sur sur saint
quentin en yvelines
on est vraiment sur 51 cents on est
vraiment je pense qu'on évoque parmi les
mieux situés avec d'autres
d'applications confrères collègues on a
une place relativement important parce
qu'on a quand même cinq établissements
sur trappe on en a sur alors la celle
saint cloud est un petit peu en dehors
mais on a on a le mérite est par exemple
donc on est vraiment sûr sur 50 ans est
très très important et on a un rapport
avec ce qui avec 50 ans kevin qui est
très très important aussi nous reste 20
secondes les prochains projets ce qui va
se mettre en place pour les us qui va se
mettre en place à lui on a déjà des
problèmes et des projections des projets
techniques en jeu par entrer dans le
technique mais il ya la mise en place
d'un ses pommes ddd contrat pluriannuel
d'objectifs et de moyens donc sur cinq
ans vous définissez vos objectifs avec
les moyens qui vont avec sur cinq ans il
faut pas se louper si vous imaginez
vous n'êtes pas dans le bon objectif
derrière ça peut vous coûter très cher
surface et le grand le grand objectif
et derrière on regarde plein au niveau
de lézards par exemple au niveau des
travailleurs il ya plein de projets et
notamment un projet de restaurant
attrape par exemple on a entre mon
travail avec monsieur moulin malandain
là dessus voilà y'a pleins pleins de
petits sujets c'est ya du boulot et on
vous souhaite bon anniversaire
merci je lui tiens d'avoir été avec nous
président de l'association pour
l'insertion l'éducation et les soins et
vous pouvez retrouver plus
d'informations sur cette association au
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran toujours attrape la cité des
métiers organise demain mardi une
opération grand job dating sur place des
représentants de renault le groupe va
recruter 350 postes en cdi sur son site
de flins dans les yvelines et des
profils de cariste mécanicien agent de
fabrication ou encore préparateur de
commandes et des métiers accessibles
sans diplôme à bac + 3 le job dating se
déroule de 9h30 à 12h30 munissez vous de
votre cv
infos et inscriptions sur le site
internet de la cité des métiers de saint
quentin en yvelines un mot de politique
à présent elle avait été élue
conseillère régionale en 2015 sur la
liste les républicains présenté dans les
yvelines babette de rozières vient
d'être déclarée inéligible pendant un an
par le conseil constitutionnel la
médiatique qu'a chef de cuisine se voir
reprocher et des irrégularités dans son
dossier de candidature aux dernières
législatives
elles étaient en lice sous l'étiquette l
air dans la 17ème circonscription de
parry babette de rozières avait ouvert
plusieurs comptes bancaires pour sa
campagne et non un seul comme l'imposent
le code électoral l'été arrive le moment
pour beaucoup de prendre des congés
chaque année cependant environ 40% des
français ne partent pas en vacances
faute de moyens c'est notamment pour
permettre à des enfants de bénéficier
d'un séjour de vacances que son a
proposé lé village copains du monde pour
en parler aline grillon bonsoir bon ça
vous êtes chargé de développement au
secours populaire des yvelines alors la
fédération organise
22 au 29 juillet la deuxième édition de
son village copains du monde c'est à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
déjà pour commencer cette interview quel
est le concept de ces villages copains
du monde
le principe c'est de
mélanger des enfants des de france donc
là en l'occurrence les yvelines et de la
marne avec des enfants qui viendront de
l'étranger donc du portugal de grèce et
d'ethiopie sur un même lieu des enfants
français et des enfants étrangers qui
vont pouvoir se réunir sur ce village
vacances et détonnant et comment
communique-t-il se parlent pas la même
langue
comment va se faire ce lien entre entre
ses enfants je pense qu'il sera
autrement dernier par le principe des
gestes des d'un mini dictionnaire pour
mettra en place et puis le le jeu du
ballon et nous avons du ballon rond
comme le foot marche très bien rentrer
les enfants ça unis will et les
différentes nationalités par exemple le
jeu du ballon le football par exemple
exactement c'est un concept qui a été
mise en place pour la première fois en
c'est un village qui avait été proposé à
gravelines dans le nord c'est ça
toujours par le secours populaire mais
mais dans le nord et d'étonnant donc en
fait l'origine des deux cc johnnie un
discours clair c'est de pouvoir donc à
la fois mixer des enfants venant
d'horizons différents mais aussi le
pouvoir parler des droits de l'enfant de
pouvoir faire la solidarité et en même
temps de proposer aux airs de vacances
du coup c'est un peu un mélange entre
séjours de la cre en solidarité droits
de l'enfant voilà pour que les enfants
sera à la fois bénéficiaire à ses jours
mais aussi acteur de de séjour et de
solidarité sas est favorisée finalement
les échanges entre des enfants de
différentes nationalités c'est aussi
s'ouvrir au maire son esprit à d'autres
nationalités d'autres cultures peut-être
aussi ça permet de pouvoir faciliter les
échanges et en même temps de pouvoir et
créer des liens et des solidarités dans
le pays mais aussi hors des murs et hors
des frontières pour élargir un peu le le
sens de l'action alors pour la
fédération des yvelines on l'a dit c'est
la deuxième édition de ce village
copains du monde si on vient sur
l'an passé comment ça comment s'est
déroulée cette première édition
l'édition elle a été déjà été mise en
place pour les 25 ans de notre mouvement
que par du monde donc qui met en avant
les solidarités par parle par et pour
les enfants et ça a coïncidé avec les 50
ans de la fédération des villes
jusqu'aux oculaire donc du coup on avait
décidé de mettre en place ce premier
village qui du coup a été a été une
réussite avec une vingtaine d'enfants
qui venait du portugal de grèce et des
yvelines et donc du coup
ça a été le lancement d'un projet qui a
été âpre et validée par nos parts pour
l'avenir par nos instances et notre
congrès qui s'est tenu en octobre
dernier à monk la ville avec un bilan
positif sert les enfants même de
nationalités différentes se sont
facilement regroupés ont pu échanger la
raison plus facilement échanger plus que
c'est facile pour eux que pour nous au
niveau des adultes
et ça nous a permis d'avoir un petit
tremblement pour plus justement pouvoir
mieux aborder une deuxième édition
l'organisme réfugiés mais c'était une
évidence après ce bilan positif de leur
proposer dès cette année une deuxième
édition de ce village naturel et
pleurant pendant ce village pardon il se
déroule je rappelle les dates du 22 au
29 juillet il y aura plusieurs
animations qui seront proposées ils
seront sur cette île de loisirs saint
quentin en yvelines
mais pas que il y aura d'autres
animations également proposer un
programme assez large d'activités qui
est prévu aussi bien des activités sur
le site de
autour d'ateliers créatifs de d'écriture
de textes droits de l'enfant d'ateliers
un peu plus sportif
du coup il faut bien il faut les faire
bouger un peu on a aussi prévu d équité
sportive avec le vélodrome l'a et le
parcours d'orientation tanakan et des
activités un peu plus un peu plus
culturelle et qui ont un sens avec le
village comme la visite du musée de
l'homme et le château de versailles donc
qui est quand même un peu symbolique sur
le territoire qu'il aurait l'idée c'est
de profiter de cet emplacement central
de l'est le loisir pour aller un peu
plus loin vers serré par exemple qui est
à dire la figure des yvelines en termes
culturels coi ces raisons que si on
avait amené des enfants de l'étranger et
de la marne est cuite et qu'il n'allait
pas au château de la cei pour un séjour
qui se passe sur les yvelines s'arrêter
un peu bizarre forcément un tel village
copains du monde nécessitent un
financement combien ça coûte
concrètement de mettre en place cette
action pour pour votre fédération alors
ce séjour ce séjour un coot 20000 euros
on a beau chercher le maximum de
gratuité ou de mise à disposition ou
d'encadrants diplômés mais bénévoles
pour justement faciliter la réalisation
du projet et quand même il y a quand
même besoin d'un mille euros de des
financements pour leurs et est donc une
cagnotte a été mise en place vous pouvez
d'ailleurs vous rendre le site a été
affichée durant cet entretien va
peut-être se ré affiche encore voilà le
site de la fédération du secours
populaire on trouve sur ce site
le lien de la cagnotte litchi pour
contribuer à voile à l'organisation de
ce deuxième village oui donc on peut
contribuer par le biais de cette
cagnotte en ligne mais aussi pour ceux
qui n'ont pas internet tout petits ont
du mal avec les les cagnottes en ligne
on peut aussi envoyer un chèque ou louis
voilà donc pas tous moyens financiers ou
seat et le doubs et on le trouve
d'ailleurs à les coordonnées postales du
secours populaire sur le site internet
une dernière question
ça témoigne de l'action du secours
populaire il ya ce village effectivement
copains du monde mais il ya une action
plus global en faveur des vacances
permettre à des enfants à des familles
pouvoir partir en vacances alors
effectivement on a le premier séjour au
lac organise pour l'été 2010 8 va
démarrer samedi pour deux premiers
dizaine de seniors qui vont aller en
alsace mais on a aussi d'autres d'autres
symboles en fait en d'autres termes de
vacances on a notamment un des symboles
forcée des familles de l'accord des
familles bénévoles du secours populaire
qui vont accueillir pendant 10 15 jours
ou trois semaines des enfants chez eux
pour les vacances pour permettre à des
enfants de pouvoir partir la france et
pour avoir aussi un enrichissement aussi
pour eux
du coup les nourritures ya je crois
qu'on a c'est l'enfant qui va partir
mais aussi pour la famille qui accueille
donc pour ça on recherche aussi et
toujours des familles de la france voilà
le message avait passé merci alinghi ont
d'abord été avec nous merci à vous du
secours populaire des yvelines vous avez
le site internet de la fédération qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
objectif faire connaître le savoir-faire
gastronomique et artisanal versaillais
la municipalité a lancé il ya quelques
semaines une boîte mystère la sélection
versailles tous les produits sont
élaborés dans la cité royale un concept
dessine destiné à un large public
découverte avec aurélie ronces retrouver
l'esprit versailles et à travers cinq
produits
ce coffret vendu 35 euros à l'office du
tourisme renferme des articles gourmands
comme cette préparation pour fondant au
chocolat mais aussi des accessoires
valeur marchande 70 euros ou répond à un
double objectif
d'abord le ver seigner qui veut partir à
l'étranger est exportée on peut
justement de sa ville
et puis le touriste qui devait partir
avec un souvenir et qui gardera autre
chose peut-être que
versailles vis de l'histoire mais aussi
versailles ville artisanale et savoir
faire
parmi les produits proposés ce
porte-clés en cuir et bois frappé du nom
de la cité royale
un objet durable dans le temps son
créateur damien béal est installé depuis
deux ans et demi à versailles
il ya plein de gens qui peuvent ne pas
connaître tous les produits locaux at le
made in versailles à des produits qui
sont fabriqués à depuis très longtemps
dans la ville le fait d'avoir cette box
avec différents produits et puis un
catalogue qui permet aussi de retrouver
d'autres adresses des lieux pour manger
des lieux à visiter des choses comme ça
je pense que c'est bien
chaque créateur dispose de sa fiche
explicative lancé au début du mois de
mai la sélection versailles est destiné
à évoluer qui est intéressant avec cette
phase test c'est qu'on va aussi
recueillir les avis pour évoluer et puis
faire évoluer le produit en fonction des
attentes
d'autres artisans versailles et pourront
se retrouver prochainement dans cette
petite boîte à l'esprit chic et les
gants le sport et du football on jouait
ce week-end la finale senior de la coupe
des yvelines sur la pelouse de maisons
laffitte et guyancourt a battu son
voisin maurepas dans un derby à
rebondissements score final 3 buts à 2
le résumé du match
camille lambert et mickaël lui d'euros
puis en cours est devenu roi des
yvelines pourtant rien n'a été simple
entre maurepas ce dimanche 3 juin à
maisons laffitte et du en cours tant été
mené au score 1 0 dès les premières
minutes de cette finale de la coupe des
épines monnaie on a été surpris un petit
peu au début de match mais bon je
connais un peu mon groupe je savais
qu'on allait très bien réagir avec le
match allait devenir intéressant ont fui
au fil du temps donc aucune inquiétude
quand on a pris deux buts fallait juste
qu'on retrouve un peu notre jeu et on
continue à jouer au ballon piqué au vif
du concours réagi pour marquer deux fois
coup sur coup avant la mi temps sur des
exploits individuels comme dans notre
retour en sont financés punir sur son
sur des contres avec des pertes de balle
à ses hôtes sa part dans tout ça va vite
chez eux on connaît ils ont été hyper
réaliste des occasions de but en
première mi temps on rentre rentrer à la
mi-temps on est mené 2 1 mais même on
n'a peut-être pas fait suffisamment en
première mi temps dans les duels dans
l'envié en seconde période les gluons
courtois continue à dominer les débats
se créent plusieurs occasions et
obtiennent un penalty non converties par
les joueurs finalement les grilles
prennent le large sur cette action sans
solution jusque là les bourses d'asie
accélèrent et réduise le score les biens
toucheront même la barre dans les dames
espoir n'évoluera plus trop à du
victoire un peu logique et parlera pas
de surprise pour moi psychologiquement
et physiquement je pense qu'on est un
peu mieux porte pas sur cette deuxième
partie de saison donc pas surpris disons
qu'on a bien préparé notre match depuis
un moment et puis on les aurait été
super motivé voulait absolument la
gagner donc les gluants courtois
terminent donc leur saison sur un titre
et une troisième place dans le
championnat de première division de
district les objectifs du club sont
atteints et genre peuvent maintenant
savourer 10 heures de concerts assurés
par neuf groupes et artistes samedi la
salle de la torah voisins le bretonneux
amis les watts pour la deuxième édition
du festival plus de 700 spectateurs ont
répondu présent miquel et demi d'euros
et mélanie poké se sont glissés parmi
eux
[Musique]
generation était l'une des têtes
d'affiché pour cette deuxième édition la
tournée les boîtes à renouveler ses dix
heures de concert cette année ne groupes
ont répondu présent c'est une volonté
l'association de pouvoir montrer tout ce
qu'on a
voilà peu de groupes locaux localement
dans les styles mais également
des fêtes affiche voilà la scène
indépendante française
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir faire la
fête un peu un saint quentin en yvelines
d'avoir un événement fédérateur et
citoyens voilà c'est ça qu'on essaie de
défendre aujourd'hui
[Musique]
de la musique sur deux scènes plus de
700 spectateurs ont fait le déplacement
yannick et alberto récemment arrivé dans
le département sont venus aux curieux
jusqu'à maintenant parce que je ne
savais pas du tout à quoi m'attendre et
je suis arrivé enfin ça fait plaisir que
les des événements comme sa liste
moi je viens passer de l'espagne vient
d'arriver ce super c'est une bonne
ambiance je retrouvais d hamid et c'est
une ville jésus christ habite maintenant
à côté je travaille comme ingénieur et
je trouve que c'est nécessaire veut
faire plus une soirée qui a pris fin à
deux heures du matin les équipes de
l'état se plonge déjà sur une troisième
édition
[Musique]
on se quitte sur ces images 3000
personnes étaient présentes samedi aux
api touahri festival un événement
musical pour fêter est les 50 ans du
parc zoologique
après une journée de visite des lieux la
soirée s'est poursuivie en concert et le
show sur scène a été assurée par le
groupe arcade yann claudio capéo et a
mis hier c'est la fin du set 8 journal
cette édition est disponible en replay
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 belle soirée
excédent de semaine à tous
[Musique]